ça fait longtemps que vous êtes pas
revenu 35 ans depuis que je suis parti
en fait laissez-moi vous présenter notre
grand écrivain Stéphane Bellecourt
à Montréal pour votre l'adaptation
cinématographique de arrête avec tes
mensonges il y a eu un avant et un après
les événements d'arêtes avec tes
mensonges c'est là qu'en quelque sorte
vous avez arrêté de vous mentir vrai ou
faux oui c'est ça c'est que au fond ce
qui se passe en 1984 quand j'ai 17 ans
ça ça fait basculer ma vie c'est accès
c'est à la fois tout bêtement la
rencontre du premier amour on pourrait
se dire bon bah finalement ça arrive à
tout le monde faut bien que ça nous
arrive non sauf que c'est un amour qui
est voué à la clandestinité parce que je
tombe amoureux d'un garçon dans la cour
de lycée et que si moi je suis prêt sans
doute à assumer la part publique de ça
lui non et lui sans forme s'enferme dans
une forme de déni et de honte quand on
dirait personne
c'est dur de l'imaginer avec des potes
qui vont précipiter à la fin de cet
amour et en même temps
ça va jouer sur le reste de ma vie et ça
va fabriquer l'écrivain que je suis
devenu
moi je resterai mais vous êtes menti
longtemps parce qu'avant vous avez fait
des études en droit social et ce n'est
qu'en 2001 que vraiment vous avez dit
c'est assez tout ça je vais vraiment
devenir écrivain comment vous avez fait
ce choix là ça a pas dû être facile de
faire votre coming out littéraire ça a
été très dur vous voulez dire parce que
j'étais un enfant très discipliné un
élève sérieux qui voulait complet à ses
parents et à ses maîtres et donc j'ai
j'ai fait des études longues j'ai suis
devenu juriste tout allait très bien
sauf que sauf que voilà j'avais j'avais
cette imagination un peu fertile qui me
titillait une facilité d'écriture et
puis un jour je me trouvais à Montréal
pour plusieurs mois parce que je
travaillais là pour l'entreprise qui me
qui m'employait à ce moment-là et je
suis allé me réfugier dans un café j'ai
commencé à écrire ce qui est devenu la
première phrase du premier livre en
l'absence des hommes qui a été publié en
et là c'est jouer quelque chose de plus
grand que moi car j'ai compris que
c'était ce que je voulais faire ou ce
que je voulais être et donc j'ai décidé
d'abandonner tout le reste donc j'ai
envoyé valdinguer ma vie professionnelle
et je suis devenu écrivain mais quand il
a fallu l'annoncer à mes parents ça a
été compliqué si avec ma mère il n'y a
pas cru on s'est dit encore un de ses
mensonges elle tenait le livre entre les
mains elle se dit qu'il raconte
n'importe quoi comme d'habitude et mon
père s'est dit mon Dieu un certain Bank
dans la famille on n'a pas mérité ça
voilà donc c'était un peu compliqué mais
finalement ils sont faits avec le temps
vous venez de me dire que Montréal a
changé votre vie parce que c'est ici que
vous avez écrit les premières phrases de
votre premier livre oui quoi à Montréal
muse sur inspiration en tout cas un
écrin qui a permis les closons du livre
donc moi je suis très sensible à la
géographie je suis très sensible au lieu
et je pense que sans doute ça serait pas
passé autrement ça serait passé
autrement ailleurs c'est-à-dire que
c'est parce que c'était là et que
c'était à ce moment-là que le livre
était devenu dans d'autres conditions
peut-être le livre c'est arrivé plus
tard ou jamais mais en tout cas c'était
nécessaire d'être là à ce moment là j'en
suis sûr parce qu'il y avait l'idée de
l'exil être loin de ces terres dans le
décalage horaire et en même temps d'être
dans un lieu où je me sentais
incroyablement bien en sécurité en tout
cas semble-t-il que vous avez une dette
envers Montréal parce que votre livre
dynam Montréal c'est le troisième de
votre série autobiographique en quelque
sorte donc vous vous sentez redevable
quand même là oui absolument parce que
je suis revenu un jour à Montréal dans
un salon et dans une dans des librairies
pour faire des rencontres et puis un
jour c'est pointé devant moi quelqu'un
que j'avais beaucoup aimé des années
avant et donc on s'est livré à des
retrouvailles amoureuses donc un peu
périlleuses et c'était encore à Montréal
comme quoi il se passe toujours des
choses dans cette ville mais moi en même
temps j'ai pas envie d'être dans la
secte que vous dirigez allez-y c'est
ma fête
de télévision française il se dit tout
est n'importe quoi oui parfois vous avez
certains coups de gueule voir comment
vous vivez ça justement à cette époque
assez trouble ou il semble y avoir un
lycée aller au niveau de la parole moi
ce qui me terrifie le plus quand je suis
sur un plateau de télé ou quand je vois
des choses à la télé c'est c'est que
alors on dit on peut plus rien dire
aujourd'hui mais si si on dit des
conneries tout le temps c'est qu'il y a
des gens qui qui balancent des insanités
des des contre-vérités et qui ne sont
jamais contredis donc moi je suis
terriblement inquiet de ça de cette
espèce de capacité à raconter n'importe
quoi à se déo populisme au complotisme
aux théories les plus farfelues à
pouvoir les exprimer au nom de la
liberté d'expression parce que la
liberté d'expression elle s'arrête ou
commence le respect de tous les autres
et le respect de la vérité en soi donc
moi ça ça m'inquiète beaucoup je trouve
aussi que sur les réseaux sociaux
défaire beaucoup de de haine et de
choses comme ça et donc c'est assez
inquiétant donc j'ai plutôt un regard
sur cette époque et sur sa sur la médiat
un peu un peu terrifiée parce que je
pense que ça manque un peu de de décence
et de respect de l'autre Philippe Bassan
merci pour cette belle rencontre merci
beaucoup
[Musique]